russia's war in ukraine is having a
major impact on food supply both in and
outside of the country the united
nations food and agriculture
organization is sounding the alarm it
says one-third of ukraine's crops may be
lost this year that's about the amount
of last year's wheat crop that could go
unharvested a similar amount of corn and
sunflower is likely to go unplanted this
spring that's because much of
ukraine's farmland lies in the war zone
many farm workers have fled and there
are shortages of fuel fertilizer and
seeds
ukraine exports about 10 of the world's
wheat and 12 percent of corn much of it
goes to african countries ukraine is
also the world's biggest producer of
sunflower oil accounting for 52 percent
of all global exports in recent years
our next report in our next report we
meet a farmer in ukraine who explains
the challenges that workers like him
face in the midst of war on a reporting
trip organized by ukrainian forces dw's
matthias berlinga met a demining group
that is turning its attention to the
country's
fields the war has left its traces on
alexandre fischoen's property alexandre
is a farmer on the outskirts of kiev he
owns a thousand hectares of farmland and
agricultural machinery
but his business has been in ruins since
russian troops entered the village at
the beginning of march
a burnt-out armored vehicle sits where
his harvest is used
they came to the gate and began rattling
my workers were inside the farm
when they realized the troops were
barging through the gate they ran over
there across the fence into the village
thank god they're all alive
the russian forces installed themselves
inside the facility and alexander fled
to kiev russian troops had occupied this
place for around three weeks and when
they left
they blew up this place
now alexander is picking up the pieces
it's not just his farmhouse that was
destroyed the fighting has also affected
his farmland it is littered with
unexploded ordnance
the minesweepers haven't been here yet
so we don't dare go out we can't work at
the moment
the mining brigades are out and about
but for now they're establishing the
damage they haven't even started
demining agricultural land for this
year's harvest it might be too late the
sowing season is nearing its end
and the military administration has
little hope they will be able to help in
time
we de-mine the roads and houses first
social facilities like schools the
things that are needed so people can
more or less walk around normally we do
the fields only after we've done that
first
he guesses it might take years for
agriculture to get back to normal
meanwhile the winter wheat is growing
alexander sowed it before the war
we've flown drones over the field
and where we see traces of vehicles
my workers have been searching for mines
with metal detectors
but we need clearance for the whole
field we don't know what's lying in
there
and we'll have to wait for the mine
sweeping team to confirm that the field
is safe
the consequences of this war will
continue to be felt far and wide as
ukraine has been feeding the world for
decades
for more let's bring in joseph schmidt
huber of the un food and agriculture
organization the fao he is the deputy
director of the fao's food and markets
division thanks for joining us dr
schmidt hubba we're seeing food
shortages and rising prices around the
globe now due to the war in ukraine
tell us more about how this crisis is
impacting different world regions
yeah perhaps it's easier to look at
consumers and producers
as far as consumers are concerned
they're ubiquitously negatively affected
so they face a lot more
to spend on food and not only on food
but also another basic necessities not
to play on fuel and
fuel for heating and for cooking and for
transportation so that leaves a lot less
money for other important issues notably
for health and education of the children
and the poorest consumers are the
hottest hit
because they spend a lot more on their
incomes than the rich consumers
so most of the the hardest hits
countries are in sub-saharan africa but
they're also um countries in the nearest
north african region the nina region
that are heavily food imported
countries and and they are as a country
very strongly affected
so africa being very strongly affected
what can be done to ease these food
shortages and stabilize the supply
yeah i think it's very important to keep
food markets open so the worst thing
that can happen is
that countries start to put their feed
on the break and essentially stop
exports so export restrictions export
taxes all measures that reduce exports
are really
detrimental to international price
stability and and countries should steer
clear of these
um at the same time i think it's
important that untarget consumer
subsidies are being reduced
take egypt for instance in egypt a
particular
type of bread costs just a fraction of
what the wheat costs to produce that
bread and that leads to a lot of waste
and a lot of use as bread as animal feed
so these things are certainly not useful
we at fao we have come up with an i
think a very interesting proposal for an
international food import financing
facility so this would essentially
afford the poorest countries with high
input needs access to credit markets so
that they can they can actually buy the
food on the international market
without driving up prices when they do
that
now some analysts say that the war in
ukraine could drag on for months if not
years what should we prepare for in the
short and medium term regarding food
supplies and the price of staples
yeah it's it's difficult to say nobody
can predict prices
and i'm certainly not going to do that
but there are signs that markets will
not find back into usual equilibria as
quickly as they normally do we have this
old adage in agriculture or in commodity
markets saying essentially that
the the best cure against high prices or
high prices in the best cure against low
prices or low prices but that is not
going to happen at the moment why
because agricultural prices of food
prices are
largely determined by energy and
particularly fertilizer prices and there
is no reason no sign to assume that
fertilizer prices will come down that
essentially means as long as fertilizer
prices are high
farmers will be hesitant to use the
normal amounts of fertilizer and that
means lower production going into 2022
2023 and that is particularly pronounced
for commodities where prices are still
well behaved like for for rice so what
we call affordability fertilizer
affordability for rice is at an all-time
low meaning that farmers have no
incentive to use the normal amounts of
fertilizers and as we've seen in in sri
lanka for instance that can lead to crop
failures to very low returns and if that
is a harbinger for the rest of asia we
could actually see a full-blown food
crisis in 2022-2023
dr schmidt thank you very much for
talking with us that was jose schmidt
from the un food and agriculture
organization
thanks for having me
you